Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
So jetzt wo Apple mitspielt ist ja Augmented Reality eine echte Sache.
Ich hab ja manchmal Probleme mit der Realität und frage mich wie man die jetzt
anreichen könnte damit es besser wird.
Also ich sag ganz ehrlich um um diese
Realität zu verbessern sehe ich für Augmentation einfach keine Zukunft.
Musik Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 463, so sieht es aus, genau. Vom 20.
Juni 2023, hallo wir sind's, Tim und Linus. Wir sagen nie wie wir heißen übrigens,
ist dir das schonmal aufgefallen?
Wir gehen mal davon aus, dass alle Bescheid wissen.
Ist das angemessen?
Weiß ich nicht.
Was ist mit dem New User Onboarding?
Wenn die Sendung beginnt mit Guten Morgen Linus, Guten Morgen Tim,
ich käme mir so ein bisschen,
das ist jetzt nochmal zu erklären,
das sind so ein paar Grundzusammenhänge, die traue ich den Leuten zu,
da würde ich sogar sagen, da setze ich voraus oder würde ich sogar sagen,
wer das nicht gebacken kriegt, der wird mit dem Rest der Sendung auch nicht viel anfangen können.
Das stimmt. Das stimmt.
Na gut, also machen wir das wie immer, wir sind's und wir biegen euch die Realität
so zurecht, dass sie erträglich wird.
Insofern machen wir eigentlich Augmented Reality seit 10 Jahren.
Auch das weiß ich nicht, ob wir uns da nicht ein bisschen weiter aus dem Fenster lehnen,
dass wir sagen diese Realität erträglich zu machen ist unser Ziel,
aber ja doch, also komm wir sind jetzt hier im Witz Einstieg,
da kann man schon mal auch ein bold Statement machen, ja okay.
Wir sind ja auch technologieaffin.
Wir machen das für euch erträglich.
Bleiben sie dran, gleich tut's nicht mehr weh.
Übrigens weil ich so technologieaffin bin, hab ich auch gleich ein neues Feature
von meinem Lieblingsservice Aufonic ausprobieren müssen. Also wer das nicht
kennt, das ist so ein Audio Dienst im Internet mit dem man Podcasts schön machen kann.
Ganz tolles ding benutze ich seit anfang an und immer noch und gerne und die
bauen letzterzeit crazy shit ein jetzt ist natürlich auch die gute alte ki AI
an den Start gekommen und ChatchiPiti wird im Hintergrund bedient.
Sprich, was ja bisher schon ging, die ganzen Transkripte die wir veröffentlichen,
die sind ja auch automatisch erzeugte Transkripte und es war ganz interessant
zu sehen wie in den letzten ein zwei Jahren die Qualität dessen immer besser wurde,
also noch vor, ich weiß nicht wann hab ich damit angefangen,
ich glaub ich mach das jetzt seit drei Jahren oder so, also schon eine Weile ne.
Und hab das dann auch erst getan, nachdem die Ergebnisse so okay waren,
so weil so richtig getroffen wurden die Worte nicht am Anfang nicht unbedingt immer,
das sprach schon in etwa dem, aber es hat dann immer so diesen Level gehabt,
wo ich mir gesagt habe okay, das ist zwar jetzt nicht so eins zu eins das was gesagt wurde,
aber man kann es schon ganz gut als Suchfutter benutzen und man kann damit bestimmte
Dinge wiederfinden und so weiter,
weil das ist ja immer das, Alte Probleme im Internet, man findet leicht irgendwelche
Sachen aber man findet halt nichts wieder und da sind natürlich dann Transkripte
ganz hilfreich dazu halt noch hier so Suchindex und pipapo in dem Moment wo
das Transkript mit in der Webseite hängt,
gibt man natürlich den ganzen Suchmaschinen auch mehr Futter.
Ja und dann ist das immer besser geworden und vor allem jetzt mit dem GPT Audio
Transkriptionssystem Whisper wurde es dann nochmal viel besser und das ist dann
irgendwie vor kurzem eingebaut worden bei Auphonic,
da hab ich dann drauf umgestellt, dann wurden auch die Transkripte nochmal ein
bisschen besser und jetzt kommt so der nächste Schritt.
Es wird nicht nur das Transkript gemacht, sondern es arbeitet sozusagen die
Maschine auch dann gleich mit ChatGPT auf diesem Transkript und fängt jetzt
an, sich quasi den Inhalt durchzulesen und seine eigene Zusammenfassung davon abzugeben.
Und das führt dann eben nicht nur in automatisch generierten Untertiteln und
Zusammenfassungen, die man
quasi nehmen kann, sondern auch zu automatisch generierten Kapitelmarken.
Ich hab dir grad mal die Kapitelmarken der letzten Sendung, die auf diese Art
und Weise generiert wurden zugeschickt und ich denke du stimmst mir zu,
dass das schon stellenweise recht beeindruckend ist, was da bei rauskommt,
weil einfach so Gesprächsaspekte herausgearbeitet werden.
Mir gefällt am besten die Kapitelmarke 43,
38.052, Smalltalk über Verletzungen und Schmerzen.
Ich weiß gar nicht mehr worüber haben wir denn da geredet.
Verletzungen und Schmerzen würde ich vermuten.
Das kann natürlich sein.
Das wäre meine Vermutung. Leider kann ich mich auch nicht dran genau erinnern.
Irgendwas zwischen Verantwortung und Datenschutz.
Aufruf zur strategischen Planung bei Fridays for Future ist glaube ich auch
marginal daneben. Ich glaube da hatten wir anderen mehr strategische Planung nahegelegt.
Den Satz kann man ja auch so lesen, aber klar es impliziert irgendwie als ob
wir diesen Aufruf durchgeführt haben, also haben wir ja auch,
wir haben ja gesagt die anderen sollen strategischer planen.
Aber klar Kritik und Kommentare zu Böhmermann und Last Week Tonight,
John Oliver und der Böhmermann Effekt, die Verdienste von Stephen Colbert und Trevor Noah,
Das ist schon, ja, Diskussion über Proteste und unsouveränen Umgang mit Demonstranten.
Ich finde es schön, wie das, also ja doch, das trifft es ja.
Und natürlich wichtig auch flexibles Mastsystem aus PVC-Fittingen zum Verkleben.
Qualität aus Europa. Das ist schon erschreckend gut.
Das ist erschreckend gut, das hat nicht dieselbe Nützlichkeit möchte ich mal
meinen wie jetzt die von uns manuell erstellten Kapitel,
weil die ja relativ klar sagen, ja gut aber das ist die von uns vorgegebene
Struktur an die wir uns ja weitgehend halten,
Aber was ich an diesen Kapitelmarken ganz gut finde ist,
dass die sagen wir mal das ganz anders zusammenfassen,
dass sie einfach mit Gesprächsdynamik und auch sagen wir mal unsere Abschweifelungen
und so Sonderpunkte hier auch noch mit eingefangen werden und ich überlege wie ich das mach,
ist jetzt ein bisschen aufwendig beides zu generieren aber durchaus machbar,
muss man nochmal gucken, ob
sich da vielleicht technisch bei euphonic nochmal was anders machen kann.
Ausrichten lässt dass man das sozusagen noch zusätzlich hat also ich würde das
einfach ganz gerne noch mal so als als edit value noch mit in die show notes rein kippen,
dass man quasi auch auf eine andere art und weise über die sendung gehen kann
als über die von uns jetzt primär ausgelieferten kapitel marken.
Also was ja leider nicht geht ist so ein hierarchisches system von kapitel marken
das sehen, Kapitelmarkenplayer, so heute nicht bevor.
Kapitelmarken haben nur H1 quasi, es gibt nicht.
Genau, das ist das Problem und das wäre eigentlich ganz interessant oder zumindest
dass man so ein alternatives Set hat,
will ich die klare Struktur wie es gedacht ist oder will ich das was letztlich
draus geworden ist, muss man nochmal schauen, aber was du noch nicht gesehen
hast ist jetzt die Zusammenfassung, also der Subtitle.
Es gibt eine Zusammenfassung der Sendung?
Ja ja genau.
Die kurze Version ist Tim Brittler von Linus Neumann diskutieren Camping,
Politik, Künstliche Intelligenz sowie PVC-Fittings und österreichische Monatsbegriffe.
Auch die DSGVO, LLMs, neuronale Netzwerke und ein orange gefärbter Privatjet
auf Sylt werden besprochen.
Das ist mal nicht falsch.
Das ist nicht falsch, aber da sind natürlich jetzt auch die zentralen Forderungen nicht mit dabei.
Genau, aber das war jetzt auch nur die Kurzversion. Die Summary ist ein bisschen
ausführlicher. Im Verlauf des Gesprächs geht es um unterschiedliche Themen von
Camping über politisches Bewusstsein bis zur künstlichen Intelligenz.
Tim Britloff und Linus Neumann diskutieren über den Unterschied zwischen den
Monaten Juni und Juli und wie sie telefonisch auseinandergehalten werden können.
Sie sprechen über österreichische Begriffe für Monate und PVC-Fittings,
die für den Bau von Teleskopstangen verwendet werden.
Sie machen auch Witze darüber, wie stolz sie darauf sind, europäische Qualität
zu verwenden und diskutieren den letzten Generationen Protest und den Umgang mit Demonstranten.
Linus Neumann berichtet von seinen Erfahrungen auf Fahrradfahrten und seinen
Beobachtungen auf der Frankfurter Allee. Er beschreibt auch,
wie einige Fahrradfahrer versuchen,
den Verband bei Critical Mass Demonstrationen aufrechtzuerhalten.
Übrigens alles auch richtig geschrieben, Critical Mass Demonstrationen.
Während einige Autofahrer aggressiv reagieren. Tim Pridloff spricht darüber,
wie dieses Verhalten auf ein Privilegiendenken der Autofahrer zurückzuführen sein könnte.
Im weiteren Verlauf des Gesprächs diskutieren Sie die Datenschutz-Grundverordnung,
DSGVO und ihre Wirksamkeit im digitalen Zeitalter.
Sie diskutieren auch über die Möglichkeiten von Large Language Models,
LLM und neuronalen Netzwerken. Es besteht die Möglichkeit, dass maschinelle
Intelligenz Arbeitsplätze übernimmt, aber auch die Chance auf mehr Freizeit bietet.
Sie sprechen auch über Cell-Broadcast-Warnungen in Deutschland und deren Wirksamkeit.
Schließlich sprechen Sie über einen orange gefärbten Privatchat auf Sylt und
die möglichen Themen für ihren Podcast.
Sie diskutieren weitere Themen wie Giftstoffe in Wolken und Verfahren zwischen
Max Schrems und Meta vor dem irischen Datenschutzgesetz.
Sie erwähnen auch die NGO Neub und suchen nach einem Full-Stack-Entwickler,
der Programmierjobs mit einem guten Zweck verbindet und als Freiberufler arbeitet.
Weißt du, so haben wir doch mal drüber geredet und welcher Sendung war denn
das und da sind dann solche Zusammenfassungen fast noch zugänglicher als Transkript.
Das stimmt ja.
Das ist tatsächlich richtig. Also Zusammenfassung ist besser.
Ja ist es. Zum zoomen.
Schön auch wie das alles hier so auf gleicher Wichtigkeitsebene ist so.
Ja wir reden über die wichtigen Themen der Zukunft der Menschheit und PVC-Fittings.
Und wie die Österreicher ihre Monate nennen.
Genau, also nur hier erfahrt ihr die wirklich wichtigen Dinge.
Das ist eigentlich alles, was ich sagen wollte.
Dann kann man ja fortschreiten mit dem Programm und über das Feedback sprechen,
was wir von euch bekommen haben, gab's nämlich wieder welches.
Okay ist das okay?
Ja mach.
Okay machen wir das doch mal und es geht los mit Cell Broadcast,
da hatten wir kurz über deine Erfahrungen gesprochen, wie du dem,
Wie ich das ignoriert habe.
Wie du der Gefahr ins Auge geblickt hast, aber nicht gecheckt hast, dass sie dich betrifft.
Paul schreibt, Cell Broadcasts sind in anderen Ländern auch nicht tief durchdacht.
Ich bekomme hin und wieder einen Amber Alert, bei dem eine verdächtige Beschreibung
inklusive KFZ Nummernschild durchgegeben werden.
Nun macht das Ding halt so einen Alarm, dass ich das hektisch am wegklicken
bin. Auf der Uhr, Privat, Iphone, Company, Iphone und mein Tablett hat auch noch eine SIM-Card.
Auf dem letzten Gerät habe ich dann auch wieder die Kontrolle über mich und
lese, was mir gebroadcastet wird.
Meist sind die Vorfälle aber 500 Kilometer weit weg.
Wenn ich dann die Straße runterfahre und mir so denke, Wait,
hast du die Nummer nicht heute früh gelesen?
Ist es dann zu spät und der Alarm ist weg. Einmal mit Profis.
Tja Paul, sagst du leider nicht welches Land das ist, das würde mir ja mal wirklich
mal interessieren, wo über Cell Broadcast verdächtigen Beschreibungen mit KFZ
Nummernschild durchgegeben werden.
Wonach klingt das?
USA.
Eigentlich schon, 500 Kilometer weit weg ist vielleicht auch so deren Vorstellung von Local,
weil Cell Broadcast hatten wir ja schon betont, soll ja nun eigentlich in einem
bestimmten Bereich nur ausgestrahlt werden, weil sonst wird es halt eben,
Wie wir hier auch lesen, ignoriert.
Ja, aber ich stimme zu, das scheint nicht sonderlich gut durchdacht zu sein.
Dann haben wir noch May, der oder die schreibt, zum Thema Cell Broadcast ist
mir aufgefallen, dass Linus meinte, dass man die Nachrichten nicht mehr lesen
kann, wenn man sie weggeklickt hat.
Ich weiß nicht, wie das bei Apple ist, aber bei Android stimmt das so nicht.
In den Einstellungen unter Safety and Emergency gibt es den Punkt Emergency
Alert History. Dort kann man alle erhaltenen Cell-Broadcast-Meldungen nachlesen.
Ich gebe zu, dass es umständlich ist, aber es ist möglich.
Interessante Information ich habe auch noch mal geguckt beim iPhone ist mir
so eine Funktionalität tatsächlich nicht bekannt so.
Ne mir auch nicht.
Was ja eigentlich.
Das ist immer wieder die Überlegenheit des Android Betriebssystems Tim,
die wir zu negieren zu hier jederzeit bereit sind.
Genau so sieht es aus. Ja, so dann gab es noch ein paar Kommentare zur letzten
Generation und unseren Äußerungen dazu.
Zweimal hier vorne weg von Katastrophe schreibt, es wird behauptet die Aktionen
der letzten Generation richteten sich an Leute die wenig Einfluss haben.
Das stimmt nicht. Die Aktionen richten sich ausdrücklich an die Regierenden.
Patrick schreibt ähnlich, das erklärte Ziel der letzten Generation ist Druck
auf die Politik auszuüben mit expliziten Forderungen. 9 Euro Ticket,
Tempolimit, Bürgerrette. Daher sind die Proteste auch weniger als PR Aktionen zu bewerten.
Läuft gut würde ich sagen.
Ja, ich meine, wenn das jetzt das erklärte Ziel ist, dann wurde es halt eben verfehlt.
Es kann ja alles sein, dass das so gedacht ist. Und nur, gut gedacht ist nicht
immer gleich gut gemacht.
Das war ja der Punkt.
Ich glaube, das Original ist, gut ist das Gegenteil von gut gemeint,
aber, ja, sehr gutes Beispiel, ne.
Also eine Diskussion, die sich die ganze Zeit wiederholt und ich glaube,
die wir auch versucht haben, in unserer letzten Sendung rüberzubringen,
ist, wenn man sich jetzt ein Ziel setzt und für dieses Ziel ein Mittel wählt,
Dann heißt das nicht automatisch, dass das Mittelgut ist?
Weil es ein bestimmtes Ziel verfolgt. Wenn es dieses Ziel nicht erreicht oder
ungeeignet ist, dann muss man eben sich über das Mittel Gedanken machen.
Und ich denke da zeigt insbesondere der Kommentar von Martina sehr klar,
warum das Mittel potenziell ungeeignet ist, oder?
Genau, sie schreibt, in der Schweiz zeigt sich der kontraproduktive Charakter
der Klebeaktionen dadurch, dass Menschen Nein zu Klimaschutzvorlagen stimmen,
weil sie gegen die Aktionen der Klimaaktivisten sind.
Egal, was der genaue Inhalt der Vorlage ist.
Das ist wirklich der gefährliche Teil. Und du musst als...
Also solange du davon ausgehst, dass deine Änderungen demokratisch herbeigeführt
werden müssen, sollen oder so, wirst du nicht umhinkommen, die Mehrheit der Leute zu überzeugen.
Und wenn du die Sympathie dieser Leute verlierst, ist das fast noch schlimmer,
als wenn du sie inhaltlich verlierst.
Also du kannst ja sogar für das Richtige argumentieren, aber unbeliebt sein,
dann wirst du daran verlieren.
So funktioniert leider dieser demokratische Rahmen, in dem wir uns bewegen.
Da gibt es eine ganze Reihe super, sagen wir mal, undemokratischer oder gefährlicher
und nicht inhaltlicher Phänomene und Effekte.
Aber die zu ignorieren führt eben auch dazu, dass man seine Ziele nicht erreicht.
So sieht es aus. Ähnlich gelagert noch der Hinweis von Felix.
Bezüglich der letzten Generation möchte ich auf ein Interview von Reinhard Steurer
im Podcast das Klima und dem Science Busters Podcast verweisen.
Steuerer ist Professor für Klimapolitik und erklärt im Podcast,
dass große Teile der Gesellschaft in einer Art Selbstverleugnung und Selbstbetrug gefangen sind.
Die Aktionen der letzten Generationen seien ein letzter verzweifelter Versuch
diese zu durchbrechen, da alle anderen Möglichkeiten bereits ausprobiert worden seien.
Wenn die Aktionen der letzten Generationen nichts nützen würden,
dann würden sie ja auch nicht schaden, denn wir seien ja ohnehin nicht auf der Siegerstraße.
Also ist alternativlos jetzt quasi?
Also das ist halt so ein, ich weiß nicht, also aus so einer,
also mag ja sein, dass hier gedacht wird, es sei schon alles ausprobiert worden.
Ich würde das bezweifeln, ja, weil man kann eine Menge ausprobieren und.
Christian Lindler lebt noch, können wir nicht behaupten, wir hätten nicht alles
ausprobiert. Tut mir leid.
Ja gut, also vielleicht auch jenseits solcher martialischen Grundideen.
Mit so einer weltuntergangsstimmung und so einem fatalismus also quasi mit so
einer negativ konnotierten botschaft und dann auch noch so mit diesem unterton
mit ist ja sowieso alles schon zu spät.
Also das führt nicht unbedingt zu aufbruchstimmung aufbruchstimmung wird mit
positiven botschaften verbunden was können wir erreichen wie schön kann es sein ja also,
Das fehlt mir einfach, nicht dass man nicht auf negative Entwicklungen hinweisen kann und auch muss,
logisch, aber die Frage ist, wie verpackst du es und wie verbindest du es eben
auch gleichzeitig mit etwas, wo alle sagen, das möchte ich gerne anstreben,
diesen Zustand möchte ich gerne erreichen.
Wenn es immer nur so um, ja nicht so schnell sterben ist oder so,
dann ist es irgendwie so ein bisschen so, ja kann ja auch weiter rauchen.
Aber wenn's einfach so eine,
das ist jetzt nicht zu sehr übertreiben, das ist jetzt nicht unbedingt gleich eine Verheißung,
aber wenn man einfach sagt, Guck mal, wie gut es sich leben lässt,
wenn die Dinge sich in diese Richtung entwickelt haben, dann ist das einfach
eine ganz andere Methode, die Aufmerksamkeit der Leute zu erringen.
Und darum geht es doch letzten Endes.
Also, mir ist das einfach alles zu steif und unempathisch.
Möchte noch eine kleine Meldung, wo ich mir, ich hoffe, die habe ich nicht schon
in der letzten Sendung wiedergegeben, aber ich glaube nicht.
In Berlin, also es wird ja viel darüber diskutiert, ist das jetzt generell Nötigung,
was die letzte Generation macht oder nicht.
Und ich habe ja gleichzeitig auch, jetzt haben wir ja relativ viel kritisiert,
dass die Methode wahrscheinlich ungeeignet ist, Mehrheiten zu formieren.
Gleichzeitig habe ich mich ja auch sehr darüber ausgelassen,
wie Menschen darauf reagieren.
Also unsouveräner Umgang mit Demonstrationen. Hat ja auch sogar ChatGPT gemerkt,
dass das ein Thema der letzten Sendung war.
Jetzt gab es ein Urteil des Berliner, also wahrscheinlich Landgericht, ne?
Landgericht Berlin und zwar wurde der Vorwurf der Nötigung abgelehnt und das Gericht erklärte,
dass die Blockaden an dem Tag angekündigt waren und dass den Autofahrenden ja
ein Umstieg auf den öffentlichen Nahverkehr oder das Einplanen von mehr Zeit generell möglich sei.
Aus diesem Grunde handelt es sich hier nicht um eine Nötigung,
vor allem weil eine Blockade von etwas mehr als einer halben Stunde in Anbetracht
der üblichen Stauzeiten in Berlin als moderat zu betrachten ist.
Urteil vom 31. Mai. Da gab es natürlich jetzt auch große, große Diskussionen.
Was dazu zu sagen ist, es geht hier um einen spezifischen Fall Und nicht generell,
dass das generell nie Nötigung ist.
Aber in diesem spezifischen Fall sagen sie, naja, in diesem Einzelfall wiegt
das Grundrecht auf Versammlungsfreiheit schwerer
als das Grundrecht auf Fortbewegungsfreiheit der blockierten Autos.
Und das hat vor allem damit zu tun, es waren nur ungefähr 35 Minuten und dadurch
kam der Verkehr nur kurzzeitig komplett zum Erliegen.
Eine Fahrspur blieb frei, da wurden die Autos dann entlang gelotst und dementsprechend
haben sie hier keine Nötigung gesehen.
Stefan Alles right. So kommen wir zu unseren Hauptthemen und jetzt geht's gleich wieder los.
Genau, ich wollte mir ja zur Angewohnheit machen, die Themen anfangs zu benennen,
damit die Leute wissen, was sie nach dem Einschlag alles verpassen.
Also wir reden über den AI-Act, wir reden über die AIDAS-Reform,
wir reden über Reddit und wir reden über den Gegenrechtsschutz.
Und in den kürzeren Meldungen haben wir doch die Huawei-Rückbaupflicht und ein
kleines Update zum Fall Radio Dreiecksland, bevor wir uns den Terminen widmen.
Chat GPT, das war jetzt die Kurzzusammenfassung, dass diese Themen sollten sich
also in den Kapitelmarken und
auch in den Zusammenfassungen der Sendungen entsprechend gewürdigt fühlen.
Was für ein leckeres Themenpotpourri wir zusammengestellt haben. Bleiben Sie dran.
Das ohnehin. Man kann ja auch auf Pause machen. Ich habe zum Beispiel so einen
Sleep-Timer bei Podcasts. Ich weiß dann so ungefähr, bei dem Podcast schlafe
ich innerhalb von 20 Minuten ein und dann geht der auf Pause.
Kann ich für uns auch empfehlen.
Ich wünsche mir ja immer noch, dass die Telefone das selber merken, dass ich einschlafe.
Psychometrische Überwachung, das ist ja eine ganz schlimme Sache,
da sind wir auch direkt beim AI Act, ja.
Psychometrisch, das ist ja einfach nur meine Atmung, das ist gern fertig.
Also das nennt man Psychometrik, also ich würde sagen der Wechsel von Wach in
Schlaf ist ein psychologisch durchaus entscheidender Wechsel deines Bewusstseinszustandes.
Und den zu überhaupt Bewusstseins- oder Erregungszustände des Gehirns zu messen,
das ist der Bereich der Psychometrik.
Ja schön. Einmal dann bitte.
Könntest du zum Beispiel im Auto, soll das ja bald sogar verpflichtend sein,
dass das Auto merkt, wenn du schläfrig bist.
Das ist mal im Auto, machen sie das dann immer. Aber zu Hause im Bett, wenn es mal wichtig ist.
Wir sind halt eine Autofahrernation.
Wir haben festgestellt, dass sie gerade eingeschlafen sind und haben extra den
Podcast für sie pausiert, haben den Podcast leiser gedreht.
Gut, dann jetzt erstes Thema.
Also es wird mit dem AI-Act eine Reihe an Dingen reguliert,
die vielleicht nicht notwendigerweise alle künstliche Intelligenz sind,
da wird einiges diskutiert in dem Zusammenhang, aber insbesondere wurde jetzt
die sogenannte intelligente Videoüberwachung diskutiert im Europaparlament.
Und da waren jetzt zwei Themen besonders entscheidend.
Das ist einmal die Echtzeit-Gesichtsüberwachung, also biometrische Erfassung.
Das heißt also, eine Person oder ein Mensch in dem Videobild wird mit einer
Biometrischen Bilderdatenbank abgeglichen, um die Personen zu identifizieren.
Achso, ich dachte, die gucken, ob mir die Gesichtszüge entgleiten.
Nee, das ist der zweite. Das ist,
automatisierte Verhaltensüberwachung, wo erkannt werden soll,
ob du etwas Verdächtiges tust.
Und dann könnte das Videoüberwachungssystem beispielsweise, sagen wir mal du
hast da jetzt so einen Bahnhof, den du überwachst mit, keine Ahnung, 590 Kameras oder so.
Und der größere Teil des Verhaltens, das Menschen dort zeigen,
wird ja sein, dass sie halt von einem Zug zum anderen gehen oder den Bahnhof verlassen.
Und jetzt macht man die Videoüberwachung ja um.
Ich weiß nicht genau, warum er die macht, aber um halt Straftaten oder verdächtiges
Verhalten irgendwie zu identifizieren und das wäre jetzt zum Beispiel,
wenn was ja in Berlin, ich muss jetzt einfach mal ein Beispiel nehmen,
mit dem ja Videoüberwachung verargumentiert wird,
insbesondere in Berlin ist, wenn du jetzt quasi einfach jemanden die Treppe
runter tritt am Bahnhof, U-Bahn-Schläger Tim, ja, das erkennt das System dann
automatisch und sagt, boah, da ist aber jetzt hier verdächtiges Verhalten.
Natürlich erhoffen die sich ganz andere Effekte, nämlich jemand,
der sich zu lange im Bahnhof aufhält, dem wird unterstellt, dass er vielleicht
gar nicht da ist, um mit dem Zug zu fahren, sondern vielleicht Drogen zu handeln oder was auch immer.
Das sind also die Ideen, mit denen solche Systeme verargumentiert werden.
Also automatisierte Erkennung von untypischem Verhalten.
Und hier hat sich jetzt das Europäische Parlament in der Position so ergeben,
dass sie sagen, die biometrische Überwachung, also die Identifikation, da sind sie dagegen.
Also das soll verboten werden. Biometrische Überwachung soll verboten werden.
Automatisierte Verhaltensüberwachung soll dagegen nicht verboten werden.
Das ist jetzt die Position, mit der das Europäische Parlament in die Trilog-Verhandlungen
mit den EU-Regierungen gehen wird.
Also noch langer Weg.
Es gibt außerdem bei dem AI-Act noch so ein paar Probleme, diese ganze Verordnung
gilt nicht für automatisierte Systeme, die ausschließlich für militärische Ziele
entwickelt oder verwendet werden.
Also die gesamten Verbote oder was in der des AI-Act schließen sich nicht auf militärische Systeme.
Es gibt relativ ausführliche Ausnahme bei Belangen der nationalen Sicherheit.
Damit dann auch insbesondere bei der Grenzüberwachung und die Definitionen werden
auch natürlich nach Belieben aufgeweicht.
Aber so zumindest jetzt erstmal der Stand der Debatte beim AI-Act.
Ist ja schon mal was.
Es gibt jetzt gerade, um ein Beispiel zu nennen, ab Juli, das ist nächsten Monat,
soll in Hamburg am Hansaplatz, das ist relativ unweit des Hauptbahnhofs,
eine intelligente Videoüberwachung stattfinden.
Und zwar genau, um verdächtige Bewegungen zu erkennen.
Und zu diesen verdächtigen Bewegungen zählen Liegen, Fallen,
Taumeln, Treten, Schlagen, Schubsen, Anrempeln, aggressive Körperhaltung und
defensive Körperhaltung.
So hat es ein Sprecher der Polizei Hamburg bezeichnet.
Also im Prinzip alles, was nicht das Verhalten ist, was man am Hansaplatz von
ordentlichen Bürgerinnen und Bürgern erwartet.
Der Hansaplatz ist ja relativ groß, in der Mitte ist glaube ich irgendwie so
eine Art Brunneninstallation oder sowas und das ist halt eine,
also man könnte schon argumentieren, dass das jetzt ein Brennpunkt ist,
ja, also da gibt es durchaus in den Straßen,
die die Region umgeben, Allerlei Menschen, die nicht einer geregelten Tätigkeit nachgehen.
Irgendwie Prostitution, Drogenhandel, sehr viel Obdachlosigkeit.
Jetzt kommt natürlich das Problem,
als Obdachloser wirst du natürlich ein Verhalten zeigen,
was nicht dem entspricht, was die Stadt Hamburg für Besucherinnen des Hansa-Platzes vorgesehen hat.
Und am Hansaplatz gibt es eben viele Obdachlose, viele davon suchtkranke und
entsprechend wird jetzt dem begegnet, nicht etwa damit, dass man sagt,
okay, wir müssen hier sozialpolitische Maßnahmen ergreifen.
So, wir müssen irgendwie diesen Menschen helfen, die sich da sammeln,
sondern wir müssen polizeiliche Überwachung machen, um die da wegzuscheuchen.
Und das ist natürlich ein bisschen mager, weil das das Problem ja nicht löst.
Damit wird ja nicht den Menschen geholfen, damit werden diese Menschen nur potenziell
vom Hansaplatz vertrieben, was, sagen wir mal jetzt, für eine aufgeklärte Gesellschaft
jetzt nicht wirklich eine Lösung des Problems ist.
Die einzige Konsequenz ist ja nur, die gehen dann irgendwo anders hin,
wo die Kameras nicht stehen und dann, was macht man dann? Dann will man da die
Kameras hinstellen oder was? Also es ist keine, dem Problem wird sich nicht genähert.
Natürlich gibt es insbesondere bei Verhaltenserkennung natürlich auch Probleme mit der Genauigkeit.
Also je nachdem wo du prüfst, gibt es unterschiedlich gute Ergebnisse,
Fehlerquote im niedriger zweistelliger Bereich. Das ist natürlich eine ganze Menge schon mal.
Mehr als zehn Prozent der Alarme sind dann eben Fehlalarme.
Also ja das kann ich mir, also ich habe so ein bisschen meine Zweifel,
dass das ausreichend gut funktioniert und wirklich dazu führt,
dass irgendetwas besser erfasst werden kann, ich meine eine andere Methode dieses
Verhalten zu erkennen ist, sich da hinstellen und hingucken.
Also für die Kosten eines solchen Systems kannst du sicherlich auch eine Kraft
damit beauftragen dasselbe zu tun.
Und dann ist es auch vielleicht naja also nicht dass da in Polizeiarbeit nicht
auch ein gewisser Beiß sein kann so aber man kann ja dann sozusagen schnell
erkennen ob irgendwas nur Getue ist oder so ich denk mal so ein jugendliches Verhalten.
Was sicherlich auch schnell als aggressiv gewertet werden kann,
aber nicht unbedingt so ist.
Ich kenne jetzt die Situation am Hansaplatz nicht besonders,
das ist halt da so hinterm Bahnhof und so. Und das ist schon,
sagen wir mal, eine Gegend, wo man sich jetzt auch nicht so gerne aufhält,
ob der Umstände, das sehe ich schon alles auch ein.
Aber ich habe ehrlich Zweifel, dass das, was man jetzt hier intendiert,
damit auch erreicht werden kann.
Ja, okay, also da gibt's natürlich auch großen Protest gegen,
weil, also nochmal, dann wird irgendwie gesagt, es geht halt los an einem Brennpunkt,
ja, aber niemandem der Menschen dort ist damit geholfen, ne?
Also, und die Situation wird nur verlagert, ist ja jetzt nicht so,
dass die sagen, scheiße Günther, jetzt haben die irgendwie Videoüberwachung
am Hansaplatz, ich muss jetzt, ich muss aufhören mit den Drogen, ja?
Also das ist ja einfach nicht das, was passieren wird.
Deswegen sollten wir diese Situation da genau verfolgen und natürlich hoffentlich
auch dem entgegenwirken.
Um den Hansa-Platz gibt es in Hamburg schon länger Thema. Ich erinnere mich,
dass ich ja schon vor Jahren mal, als ich in Hamburg war, bei Demonstrationen
war, die sich mit dem Thema auseinandergesetzt haben.
Und Videoüberwachung, ich weiß nicht, es ist so ein bisschen traurig,
wenn du dir überlegst, was es also für Probleme gibt.
Und dann denken die so, ja voll geil, wir müssen so viel mit Kameras überwachen,
das können wir keinem Menschen mehr zumuten.
Jetzt brauchen wir Computer, die mit Kameras irgendwie diesen Konformitätsdruck
in die Gesellschaft tragen.
Naja, schon ein bisschen dystopische Ideen, die wir hier diskutieren.
Naja, es ist halt dieselbe Geschichte, Videoüberwachung hat man jetzt gemerkt,
ist dann doch extrem problematisch, einerseits ist es halt schlecht zu überwachen,
weil da muss man dann die ganze Zeit gucken und interpretieren und so weiter
und das ist aufwendig und teuer und außerdem regen sich die Leute auf,
wenn sie sozusagen direkt gesehen werden, das ist so ein bisschen auch so das
Analogon zu diesen Terahertz-Scannern.
An flughafen also gab es
ja dann so ein bisschen auch den protest so
die komplette durchleuchtung dort vorzunehmen na zu stichwort nacht nackt scanner
lösung war software drüber zu gießen die dann eben quasi ein gefiltertes bild
abstrakt auf den bildschirm bringen wo auf bestimmte stellen hingewiesen wird
wo man nochmal gucken muss sicherlich auch wenn man brauchbarer.
Kompromiss gewesen in der Hinsicht, aber das mit dem Verhalten interpretieren
ist ja im Prinzip jetzt eine automatisierte Auswertung der Videoüberwachung.
Das Videobild existiert ja immer noch, wird aber jetzt nicht als solches betrachtet
und es wird eben auch nicht,
wenn dieser AI Act entsprechend durchkommt, Nicht
automatisiert vorgenommen aber es wird eben abstrakt drauf geschaut und das
ist natürlich genau das wo jetzt machine learning und die ganzen Techniken die
hier kommen absehbar tatsächlich gute Ergebnisse erzielen werden können,
Das klingt jetzt zwar gerade noch so ein bisschen danach,
dass das technisch ein Aufwand ist, der stark fehlen kann und sicherlich auch
noch tut, aber das sehe ich jetzt in der technologischen Entwicklung sehr wohl,
dass solche Analysen möglich sind.
Ich meine wir haben jetzt AIs, die schauen sich Filme an und können dir dann
eine Zusammenfassung davon zeigen.
Und das wird schon kommen und
das hat aber dann auch natürlich nochmal ein anderes
Bedrohlichkeitspotenzial weil in dem Moment wo dann Intention analysiert wird
dann wird sie natürlich damit auch implizit unterstellt und dann sind wir halt
schon wirklich bei einem Minority Report wo dir dann quasi nahegelegt wird so
naja du wirst diese Straftat begehen weil der Computer says yes.
Es ist auch stark dieses, also überhaupt diese Idee, hier darfst du dich jetzt
nicht verdächtig verhalten.
Du weißt aber nicht genau, was verdächtiges Verhalten ist, ne?
Also es ist schon ne, ich bin mal gespannt, also ich glaube,
ich werde mal da, wenn das da ist, wenn ich nächstes Mal in Hamburg bin,
schon auch mal überlegen, wie...
Wie du dich verdächtig verhalten kannst?
Wie ich ja oder wie ich möglichst unverdächtig über den Ansatzplatz komme.
Naja, weiß ich nicht.
Was kaufen? Wer kaufen kann kein falscher Bürger sein.
Ja genau, hat Geld ausgegeben, herzlich willkommen. Ja,
okay, also ein, ein, es ist wirklich ein, also es ist, es ist einfach schade
mit welchen Ideen wir auf die Probleme der Gesellschaft hier versuchen einzugehen.
Und da gibt es unterschiedliche Herangehensweisen.
Einige davon sind geeignet, das Problem an der Wurzel zu verbessern.
Andere sind geeignet, das Problem woanders hin zu scheuchen.
Und historisch haben die, mit denen das Problem woanders hin scheuchen,
irgendwie nicht so einen guten Track Record.
So, kommen wir zum nächsten Thema. Das nächste Thema ist die EIDAS-Reform.
Die EIDAS-Verordnung soll die Grundlage schaffen für eine europäische digitale Identität,
die European Digital Identity Wallet,
abgekürzt ID-Wallet, und das ist also der erneute Versuch,
Ausweismöglichkeiten, Identitätsnachweise in die digitale Welt zu bringen,
nicht nur bei Verwaltungsgängen, Bankgeschäften, sondern vielleicht auch bei
Arztbesuchen, Alterskontrollen, Konzerttickets, Hotelbuchungen, ja, also eine, einen...
Homogenisierten Identitäts- und Schrägstrich-Capability-Altersnachweis zu schaffen.
Die Probleme dabei sind natürlich primär im Bereich erstens der Überidentifikation,
weil es einfacher wird, überall mal eben kurz nach dem Ausweis zu fragen.
Und daran anbindend Tracking, Profiling und gezielte Werbung.
Wenn Leute dich, wenn man jetzt, wenn du dich erstmal daran gewöhnt hast,
sich bei allen möglichen Gelegenheiten zu identifizieren, dann freuen sich natürlich
diejenigen, die dich über unterschiedliche Plattformen tracken und so weiter.
Da gibt es jetzt einen offenen Brief,
der von insgesamt 22 Organisationen der Zivilgesellschaft veröffentlicht wird,
unter anderem, oder ich glaube,
erst Unterzeichner oder Autorin ist dann Epicenter Works, also der,
die NGO, die Thomas, hat er die gegründet? Ja, hat er.
Und er sagt also, in der aktuellen Form gibt es ein großes Risiko,
weil es wenig Unterscheidung zwischen legitimen und betrügerischen Szenarien der Anwendung gibt.
Und sagen also in dieser Form ist es eigentlich einfach nur ein Geschenk an
Google und Facebook weiter die Privatsphäre von EU-Bürgerinnen.
Zu unterminieren.
Aktuell findet die Überwachung statt mit illegalen Device Fingerprinting,
also irgendwie Nutzerverhalten.
Alles, was man über das Gerät findet, wird in Verhaltensprofile reingeschoben
und wenn du jetzt dort nur die Möglichkeit hinzugibst,
das mit der tatsächlichen Identität zu verbinden und dann eben Verhalten in
der öffentlichen und in der privaten Welt sehr genau zu erfassen und zu korrelieren,
dann schaffst du hier ein riesengroßes Überwachungs- und Ausnutzungspotenzial.
Entsprechend verlangen sie dagegen einen Schutz.
Und das betrifft natürlich erst mal Regeln, also gesetzliche Regeln,
aber natürlich auch technische Möglichkeiten, diese Ausnutzung zu behindern.
Und das ist nicht so einfach, ja.
Und ich denke, einerseits, klar, wird man hier technische Methoden brauchen,
aber natürlich auch rechtliche Dinge, die es einfach verbieten.
Also einerseits sollte es technisch so schwer wie möglich gemacht werden.
Und zweitens eben auch die Nutzung dieser Daten rechtlich stark eingeschränkt werden.
Gleichzeitig ist der Aspekt, wenn du einmal eine Person identifiziert hast,
dann wirst du es natürlich merken, also wäre es ja doof, das nicht zu tun.
Entsprechend sollte die Technik natürlich auch derart gestaltet sein,
dass sie das verhindert oder nicht ermöglicht.
Das BMI hat jetzt gerade angekündigt, dass sie die Öffentlichkeit und Expertinnen
frühzeitig in die Entwicklung einer ID-Wallet einbinden wollen und diese soll
an bestehende Infrastrukturen andocken.
Da kann man jetzt direkt schon sagen, ja geil, was ist jetzt mit den bestehenden
Infrastrukturen gemeint und welche habt ihr denn da, die gut sind,
an die man andocken kann?
Sie wollen also jetzt eine Konsultation durchführen, die insgesamt aus drei Workshops besteht.
Dafür kann man sich bis zum Ende des Monats beim BMI bewerben und am 30.
November, also August, September, Oktober, in diesen drei Monaten werden dann
offenbar diese drei Workshops stattfinden.
Und dann wird ein Konzept für eine prototypische EU-DI-Brieftasche,
European Digital Identity-Brieftasche, öffentlich vorgestellt werden.
Und dieses Konzept soll dann vom Konsortium Potential in konkrete Anwendungsfälle
überführt und darin getestet werden.
Dieses Potentialkonsortium ist ein französisch-deutsch geführter Zusammenschluss
mit privatwirtschaftlichen der öffentlichen Partner des 19U starten.
Die Frage mit so einer Konsultation ist natürlich irgendwie,
tja, willst du da jetzt mit dabei sein oder nicht?
Auf eine Weise lieferst du denen deine Anforderungen, Kritik,
potenziellen Kritikpunkte, früh frei Haus, was niemals zu deinem Nachteil sein sollte.
Also, es ist ja gut, wenn du dich jetzt als Organisation früh hier einbringst
und sagst, pass auf, das und das und das sehen wir als Probleme,
dafür braucht ihr Lösungen.
Gleichzeitig ist es natürlich so, dass viele Leute nicht zu Unrecht das ganze
Ding, die ganze Idee als Problem sehen, weil dieser Effekt der Überidentifikation
einfach nicht wegzukriegen sein wird.
Es werden einfach Menschen daran gewöhnt, öfter sich zu identifizieren.
Und das ist in den seltensten Fällen tatsächlich notwendig.
Insofern argumentiere ich ja auch immer dafür, dass man hier eben einzelne Capabilities,
einzelne Berechtigungen nachweist und nicht seine Identität.
Was eben zum Effekt haben könnte, dass wenn das Ding dann irgendwann mal vorgestellt
wird, dass sie im Prinzip damit werben könnten und sagen, dann guck mal hier,
was wir für ein geiles Konzept gemacht haben mit Input.
Was weiß ich, des CCC oder Input von der und der Gruppe.
Entsprechend weiß ich noch nicht genau. Ich meine, natürlich kann man auch,
wenn man jetzt nicht dahin geht, wird es einem nachher als Vorwurf gemacht.
Es ist potenziell, würde ich das jetzt erstmal als einen guten Schritt werten
in der Entwicklung eines solchen Konzeptes,
dass hier Leute sich einbringen dürfen.
Wie gut das umgesetzt wird, wird sich aber daran zeigen, ob das Input auch genutzt
wird oder nicht und ob das am Ende bei der EIDAS-Reform berücksichtigt wird.
Wenn hier jetzt schon mal dieses Potentialkonsortium oder wie das heißt,
daran gebunden ist und Dinge umbauen soll in den Piloten,
dann könnte das ein sehr mächtiger Weg sein, sich dort einzubringen und vielleicht
das Schlimmste zu verhindern und vielleicht noch die eine oder andere gute Idee
einzubringen, wäre mal wirklich was Neues.
Ja, also ich denke, da kann man mit gemischten Gefühlen hingehen und ich bin
mal sehr gespannt, was dabei rauskommt.
Auf jeden Fall, sag ich mal, Einbindung der Zivilgesellschaft ist eine Forderung
und dieser Dieser wird jetzt nachgegeben jetzt mal schauen ob dieses einbinden
auch mit einfluss einhergeht oder nicht.
Ich meine das ist natürlich immer die frage beteiligst du dich und dann wirst
du ignoriert und dann war die ganze arbeit für nix und trotzdem wird dann gesagt
so wieso hast du ja nicht durchsetzen können so ein bisschen mit schuld auch so ein bisschen.
Demokratie, wenn du dich hier gegen deine Grundrechtsideen...
Ja, aber wenn du es halt gar nicht machst, dann greift natürlich auch der Vorwurf,
wenn du nichts dazu beiträgst und hast dich hier die ganze Zeit nur auf der
Straße geklebt und nicht irgendwie mitgeholfen.
Das ist dann halt auch so ein Argument.
Hast du dich auf die Straße geklebt, Tim?
Ich kleb mich hier gleich auf die Straße.
Also ich bin mal sehr gespannt, wie das da läuft. Wir beobachten das als,
ja sagen wir mal, zwiespältig.
Aber auf jeden Fall, also Beteiligung ist gut.
Diese Beteiligung muss natürlich auch mit Einfluss einhergehen.
Da wird man es am Ende sehen, was denn da so das Ergebnis der Konsultation ist.
Und daran wird man sie bewerten müssen. So Tim, hast du mitbekommen,
was da bei Reddit los ist?
Ich muss zugeben, dass ich bis heute noch nicht so im Detail verfolgt habe,
aber soweit ich das mitbekommen habe, ist der CEO von Reddit ein richtig großer
Elon Musk Fanboy geworden,
schaut sich an was so bei Twitter abgeht und denkt sich so, also mal so richtig
die Company mit ihrer ganzen Community in die Scheiße reiten, das kann ich doch auch.
Also das ist ein Thema, bei dem ich schon sehr viele Kommentare sehe,
weil ich zugeben muss, dass ich Reddit eigentlich überhaupt nicht nutze.
Und mir hat sich das auch nie so wirklich erschlossen und es ist mir selten
gelungen, aus Reddit irgendwie sinnvolle Informationen zu beziehen.
Ich weiß aber, dass das irgendwie für viele Leute eine super wichtige Community
ist, wo sie sehr viel herbeziehen.
Einerseits Fachwissen, andererseits wichtige Memes für den Alltag.
Und das ist also eine Plattform, die viele Menschen nutzen, die sich mir irgendwie
nie ganz erschlossen hat.
Naja, ich meine Reddit ist natürlich insofern so ein bisschen...
Oder sagen wir, die hat sich mir schon erschlossen, aber die hat es nicht geschafft,
meinen Alltag zu bestimmen.
Das geht mir auch genauso. Reddit ist so ein bisschen das bessere Webforum,
es hat halt irgendwie geschafft im Web solche Diskussionsgruppen am Leben zu
erhalten, hat sich ein Moderationssystem geschaffen, was für viele Gruppen offensichtlich sehr gut funktioniert.
Es gibt auch viele Gruppen die sind so ein bisschen out of their mind aber es
gibt da eben auch sehr viele professionelle Gruppen, Leute die einfach Special
Interest haben und es gibt eigentlich für jeden Special Interest gibt es halt
bei Reddit auch irgendwie eine Gruppe.
Und teilweise hat natürlich auch eine relativ liberale Zugangspolitik hier eine Rolle gespielt,
unter anderem gab es halt sehr fähige Clients mit denen man wunderbar mit Reddit
arbeiten konnte, so ähnlich auch wie bei Twitter.
Und da das viel zu gut funktioniert hat, denken sich jetzt halt die Chefs bei
Reddit so, die missbrauchen ja hier sozusagen unser Produkt und verdienen sich
ja an uns eine goldene Nase.
Das muss ein Ende haben, wir schränken jetzt mal den API Zugang ein,
sodass dann eben Kosten aufgerufen werden für den Zugang, der dann einfach nicht mehr darstellbar ist.
Also konkret geht's da vor allem um eine App, wenn ich das richtig mitbekommen habe, Apollo für iOS.
Für das iPhone hab ich auch installiert, also benutze ich selten aber hab ich halt mal so benutzt,
weil das eben so eine ordentlich programmierte App ist,
wo irgendwie alles einem sich sinnvoll erschließt,
so komplexe Systeme tendieren ja dazu irgendwann nur noch Unsinn zu präsentieren
und wer schon mal irgendwie versucht hat mit Facebook zu arbeiten weiß wahrscheinlich
wovon ich rede und es gibt auch die Reddit Webseite ist so ein Rätsel für sich,
ist schon mal kein gutes Zeichen, dass es eine neue Webseite und auch noch oldreddit.com.
Gibt für Leute, die mit der neuen Version nicht klarkommen, naja,
aber durch die angekündigten API Änderungen werden also jetzt theoretisch Kosten
für Third-Party Entwickler aufgerufen,
die halt einfach durch die Umsätze, die sie mit ihren Usern erzielen,
die also quasi Subscription-Pricing machen für ihre App, in der Regel,
ja, das einfach nicht covern können.
Das bedeutet dann im Prinzip das Ende dieses offenen Ökosystems.
Man soll wieder auf die Haus App umgeleitet werden.
Die habe ich jetzt nicht benutzt, muss ich ehrlich gesagt zugeben.
Aber wenn das halt so ist wie bei Twitter, dann halt gute Nacht.
Ja, also der Punkt mit der Reddit-API ist natürlich, was die...
Also, was die API nicht ausspielt, ist Werbung.
Also das ist das Kernargument von Reddit, zu sagen, naja, okay,
wenn die Werbung ist halt unser Geschäftsmodell, wenn die nicht mit ausgespielt
wird, dann haben wir ein Problem.
Und wir sagen, wir geben gratis API-Access für nicht kommerzielle Forscherinnen und Akademikerinnen.
Aber wir Wir möchten diese Dritt-Applikationshersteller nicht wirklich weiter fördern.
Das Problem sind ja eigentlich gar nicht diese Dritthersteller,
sondern deren Vorstellung davon was man damit verdienen soll,
weil die Kosten jetzt für diese Apollo Software läge halt irgendwie im Bereich
von mehreren Millionen im Monat, so einfach überhaupt nicht darstellbar.
Und andererseits könnte man ja auch sagen, Leute zahlen ja vielleicht auch für
einen werbefreien Zugang, ne?
Ja, ja, klar.
Also wäre ja auch eine Option. Macht ja, wie YouTube das zum Beispiel macht.
Also ich bin glücklicher YouTube Premium Kunde. Kann ich jetzt hier mal gleich zugeben.
Ich zahle da mein Geld und ich sehe nicht einen Clip auf YouTube.
Ich habe total vergessen, dass es da mal Werbung gab.
Peace of mind. Ich benutze jetzt nicht so sehr viel Zeit Party Apps mit YouTube
aber geht zum Beispiel auch.
Ok lasst uns vielleicht bevor wir jetzt irgendwie über eine Community richten
die wir beide nicht so wirklich nutzen also Fakt ist es gibt eine ganze Reihe
Reddit Moderatorinnen und Userinnen die da überhaupt nicht von überzeugt sind.
Und die dagegen protestieren ja und die haben jetzt irgendwie was haben sie
ein Blackout gemacht, dann haben sie einfach im Prinzip die ganzen Communities
private geschaltet, was haben sie doch gemacht?
Das weiß ich nicht das ist das einzige was ich mitbekommen habe.
Sie haben auch glaube ich irgendwann das Ding nochmal mit, war das John Oliver oder sowas geflutet?
Also das war halt die Pics Gruppe, es gibt ja so ein R slash Pics wo es halt
um Bilder geht und da wurde dann abgestimmt wie denn jetzt damit umgegangen
werden soll und es gab glaube ich zwei Optionen irgendwie,
ich weiß gar nicht was die eine Option war, wir machen jetzt hier Business as
usual oder wir posten nur noch sexy Pictures von John Oliver und das war auch
wie 70% John Oliver und seitdem gibt es nur noch sexy Pictures von John Oliver,
also was natürlich irgendwelche Collagen von John Oliver sind aber wir haben
ja nun hier ausführlich auch über John Oliver gesprochen.
Der hat einen gewissen Status sagen wir mal in dieser Netzwelt und ja deswegen
findet da halt derzeit nur das statt.
Inwiefern das jetzt die Grundfesten von den Reddit CEOs irgendwie erschüttert
da hab ich so ein bisschen meine Zweifel.
Aber es ist schon mal schön zu sehen, dass alle Spaß haben und sich da ein bisschen
Kreativität entlädt, wie es das ja eigentlich auch sonst dort tut.
Ob das jetzt dazu führen wird, dass die ihre Pläne ändern, kann ich ehrlich
gesagt nicht einschätzen.
Die haben da irgendwie so ein...
Irgendwie ihren Konflikt da jetzt, dieser Steve Huffman hat dann gesagt,
wir werden nicht einknicken und hat dann auch irgendwie gesagt,
naja, so sinngemäß, warte mal, er hat leicht gedroht und hat gesagt,
so dieses mit den Moderatoren, das könnte ich mir vorstellen,
dass das auch andere machen wollen oder so, ne?
Also hat er jetzt auch eine maskische Art,
damit halt dieser Community, also Leute,
die da teilweise massenhaft Kommentare moderieren für irgendwie ein Unternehmen,
was damit Gewinne macht, Also da hat er irgendwie, er schafft es wirklich diesen
Konflikt jetzt irgendwie auf eine Weise zu spielen,
wo es ihm nicht gelingt für seine Belange in dieser Angelegenheit gutes Verständnis herzustellen.
Und jetzt passiert eigentlich das, was ich überhaupt interessant finde.
Jetzt mischt sich Black Cat ein.
Black Cat ist eine Ransomware-Gang, die ALPHV,
also A-L-P-H-V, slash Black Cat heißt,
und die im Februar 80 Gigabyte Daten von Reddit extrahiert hat.
Die haben mit einem Phishing-Angriff Erfolg gehabt und haben 80 GB Daten extrahiert
und haben im April und im Juni Reddit angeschrieben und haben gesagt,
wir drohen euch übrigens mit der Veröffentlichung dieser Daten.
Reddit hat darauf nicht reagiert, also sie haben quasi auf diesen Erpressungsversuch
nicht reagiert, haben auch nicht gesagt, okay, zeigt mal, welche Daten ihr habt,
damit wir einschätzen können, was hier passiert ist.
Übrigens, das nur am Rande, ein Schritt, zu dem ich eigentlich doch in der Regel
raten würde bei einem solchen Fall, weil welche Daten die Angreifer haben,
verraten sie dir kostenlos.
Das müssen sie dir kostenlos verraten, weil sie damit natürlich ihre Erpressung aufrechterhalten.
Und Das gibt dir immerhin den Vorteil, dass du weißt, welche Daten sie haben.
Das heißt, du kannst dich darauf vorbereiten, was passiert, wenn sie veröffentlicht werden.
Also auch wenn du kein Interesse hast, mit denen zu verhandeln und auch kein
Interesse hast, zu zahlen,
macht es eigentlich Sinn, sich dieses File-Listing geben zu lassen,
um für den Zeitpunkt der Veröffentlichung vorbereitet zu sein.
Das nur als allgemeinen Aspekt.
Das lastet Black Hat denen auch an und sagen, ja, hier, die haben niemals gefragt, was wir haben.
Und jetzt sagt Black Cat, naja, wir verlangen jetzt viereinhalb Millionen und
dass ihr diese API-Änderungen rückgängig macht.
Ein neuer Player betritt diesen Rahmen. Ich würde das insgesamt als Scham-Offensive
dieser Ransomware-Gang bewerten,
die jetzt im Prinzip einfach nur versuchen, also, naja,
einerseits sich, naja, den Druck auf Reddit zu erhöhen, sich selber so ein bisschen
so einen Robin Hood Anstrich zu geben und, naja, letztendlich,
also, es ist halt ein PR-Gag, ne?
Reddit wird unter keinen Umständen sagen, oh ja, ne, jetzt,
jetzt, wo ihr die Nutzerdaten oder wo ihr irgendwelche internen Daten droht
zu veröffentlichen, Jetzt nehmen wir die API-Änderungen zurück,
während unsere gesamte Community versucht, seit Monaten oder seit Wochen irgendwie unter Druck zu setzen.
Ist natürlich Quatsch, dass das passiert wird, aber ich find's auf jeden Fall
einen lustigen Plottwist, dass hier die Kriminellen sagen, Ach guck mal,
das Unternehmen, das hat gerade auch nur eine öffentliche Auseinandersetzung.
Lass uns mal hier die Forderung mit aufnehmen in unseren Katalog.
Lass uns mal die Guten spielen.
Ja, lass uns mal die Guten spielen. Gleichzeitig trotzdem, was wird passieren?
Reddit wird nicht zahlen und dann werden diese Leute oder die Ransomware Gang
wird natürlich, wird früher oder später diese Daten veröffentlichen.
Und ja, dann wird in der Regel, so viel passiert ja nicht wegen der Veröffentlichung.
Und potenziell sind die Leute, auf deren Seite sich die Angreifer jetzt hier
stellen, je nachdem auch potenziell von diesem Datenleak betroffen. Also zweifelhaft.
Aber ich fand es einen lustigen, einen Plottwist, der hier die Erwähnung sich verdient hat.
Alright mal gucken wie es weitergeht mit Reddit. Es gibt ja dann auch gleich
wieder Aufbruch ins Fediverse etc.
Ist natürlich jetzt auch ein Thema.
Wir flüchten jetzt alle von der Plattform wie schon bei Twitter.
Mal gucken ob das in irgendeiner Form Beine hat.
Also ich kann auf jeden Fall sagen die Open Source Alternativen die erschließen
sich mir genauso wie Reddit. Also das scheint ihnen sehr gut gelungen zu sein.
Es gibt einen neuen Rechtshilfe-Fonds von FragDenStaat, den ich auch sehr unterhaltsam finde.
Anna habe ich da heute drauf hingewiesen. Und zwar, ich zitiere mal aus der Ankündigung.
Rechte Netzwerke mahnen ab und verklagen, um Druck auf Menschen aus Aktivismus,
Politik, Wissenschaft und Journalismus auszuüben.
Ihr Ziel, Betroffene sollen eingeschüchtert und von ihrer wichtigen Arbeit abgelenkt
werden. werden. Der öffentliche Diskurs zu antidemokratischen Rechten soll erstickt werden.
Eine neue Studie des Instituts für Demokratie und Zivilgesellschaft zu rechten
Abmahnstrategien zeigt, der Einsatz von juristischen Mitteln von rechts hat
seit spätestens 2015 deutlich zugenommen.
Mehr als die Hälfte der Betroffenen von Abmahnungen hätten Expertise zum Umgang damit gebraucht.
Mehr als drei Viertel der Personen, die sich nicht gegen die Angriffe gewährt
haben, haben das aus finanziellen Gründen getan.
Die einzelnen Betroffenen haben oft nicht ausreichend Mittel und sachverständige
Unterstützung, um gegen die juristischen Angriffe vorzugehen.
Um das jetzt noch kurz zu kontextualisieren.
Abmahnungen sind also der Mechanismus einer Abmahnung ist ja,
du verlangst im Prinzip einfach nur Geld und Unterlassungserklärungen.
Und das im Prinzip ja außergerichtlich.
Und jetzt kannst du natürlich zu viel verlangen. jetzt kannst du irgendwie übermäßige
Unterlassungserklärungen verlangen,
du kannst vielleicht sogar einen rechtlichen Anspruch gar nicht haben,
du kannst also, sag ich mal, ein Vergehen unterstellen, was gar nicht wirklich zulässig ist. aber,
Wenn eine Person sagt, ich mach das nicht, dann dafür bedrohst du sie eben mit einer Anzeige.
Also mit weiteren Schritten, die potenziell teurer sind.
Und wenn du das jetzt mit einer juristischen Leihen machst, dann wird die potenziell
sich eben durch deine Abmahnungsforderungen ausreichend bedroht sehen und Angst haben,
sich dagegen zu wehren, weil sie das Risiko vermeiden möchte,
dass die Kosten noch höher sind.
Entsprechend formulierst du natürlich auch deine Abmahnung, die wird ja von
Anwältinnen und Anwälten geschrieben.
Und ja, so üblicherweise ist eine Abmahnung so, dass du darauf nicht eingehen
solltest, aber um zu wissen, wie du darauf korrekt reagieren musst,
um einerseits den wirklichen Anspruch gerecht zu werden.
Andererseits den nicht begründeten Anspruch abzulehnen.
Dafür brauchst du halt eine Anwältin und in der Regel kostet die die schon mehr als die Abmahnung.
Deswegen funktionieren ja diese Systeme wie Waldorf-Rommer und wie heißen die
anderen Abmahner so gut, weil die Menschen Angst haben.
Wir haben ja auch hier diesen Aspekt der Google-Fonds-Abmahner,
wo sich nachher herausgestellt hat, dass sie das gewerbsmäßig und unberechtigt
und rechtsmissbräuchlich und so weiter getan haben.
Wir haben natürlich trotzdem riesige Erfolge gehabt, denn eigentlich hätte jede
einzelne Person, die da abgemahnt wurde...
Das potenziell nicht zahlen müssen, aber jede einzelne Person oder die,
die gezahlt haben, haben sich eben dagegen entschieden, aus Angst,
dass es noch teurer wird, aus Faulheit oder was auch immer.
Entsprechend, um dieses finanzielle Risiko des Zuwehrsetzens zu reduzieren,
gibt es jetzt von FragDenStaat den Gegenrechtsschutz.
Der Gegenrechtsschutz ist Infrastruktur gegen rechte Angriffe auf Meinungs-,
Presse-, Kunst- und Wissenschaftsfreiheit.
Das Projekt verteidigt Menschen gegen zivilrechtliche Ansprüche,
wie es bei einer Abmahnung der Fall ist.
Wer von der extremen Rechten abgemahnt oder verklagt wird, sei es wegen eines
Artikels, eines Tweets oder eines Theaterstücks, kann sich an den Gegenrechtsschutz
wenden. Wir beraten schnell, unkompliziert und kostenlos.
Wenn nötig, können wir auch eine zivilrechtliche Verteidigung organisieren,
vernetzen oder finanzieren.
Also beraten Betroffene, finanzieren und organisieren anwaltliche Hilfe und
wenn nötig Gerichtsverfahren,
bauen Netzwerke für und mit Betroffenen auf, bündeln die rechtliche Expertise
und sie erfassen und strukturieren alle Fälle, um eine Grundlage für die weitere
Auseinandersetzung mit rechten Abmahnstrategien zu liefern.
Das erste Verfahren ging es um Hans-Georg Maaßen.
Im ersten Fall des Gegenrechtsschutzes waren wir bereits überwiegend erfolgreich.
Wir haben den Aktivisten Sahak Ibrahim Kiel, ich hoffe, ich habe das jetzt korrekt
ausgesprochen, bei der Verteidigung gegen Abmahnung des Ex-Geheimdienstlers
Hans-Georg Maaßen und des Publizisten Roland Tichy unterstützt.
Wunderschön. Tichy, der mit Tichys Einblick, sozusagen so ein rechtes Magazin.
Wer weiß, ne? Maaßens Anwalt Ralf Höcker hatte unter anderem eine Verletzung
der Persönlichkeitsrechte von Maaßen moniert und Unterlassung verlangt.
Und dieses Unterlassungsbegehren konnte der Anwalt vom, des gegen Rechtsschutz
weitgehend, in weiten Teilen zurückweisen und daraufhin hat Maaßen dann auf
die Ansprüche verzichtet.
Guck an, auf einmal war es dann doch nicht so wichtig.
Ja, dann ist der Rechtsstaat auf einmal doch nicht mehr so gut,
ne? Der Gegenrechtsschutz ist gemeinbeziehungs- und spendenfinanziert.
Ein zivilgesellschaftlicher Beirat stellt sicher, dass die Ziele des Projekts
eingehalten werden. Da gibt es also verschiedene Menschen, die da in diesem Beirat sind.
Und das sieht erstmal alles ganz interessant aus.
Ja, schöne Aktion.
Genau. Es gibt da auch noch mal weitere Informationen dazu. Erstens ja,
wie man wieder genau aufgebaut ist. Ich packe das mal auch mit in die Shownotes.
Und was es für Betroffene bedeutet, abgemahnt zu werden. Ja,
auch relativ klar. Ja, Titel lautet im ersten Moment war ich einfach nur überfordert.
Und Abmahnungen sind ein unangenehmes oder ein häufig missbrauchtes Mittel.
Als Idee grundsätzlich ist Abmahnung nicht so schlecht, aber sie werden eben
leider sehr viel missbraucht in der Berichterstattung.
Auch in Urheberrechtsfragen, denke ich, haben wir ja ganz klar in großen,
weiten Teilen relativ viel Missbrauch dieses Rechtsmittels zu beklagen.
Ein mehrmals fast totgesagtes Thema erlangt wieder Konjunktur.
Und zwar findet jetzt, also wir haben es hier öfter behandelt.
Es gibt Mobilfunknetze und es gibt Hersteller der Technologie dafür.
Diese Herstellerbewegungen befinden sich in der Regel nicht mehr in Deutschland
oder die nennenswerten Marktvertreter befinden sich nicht mehr in Deutschland.
Und diejenigen, die sich in der Europäischen Union befinden,
sind auch nicht unbedingt unter den Nennenswerten aufzuzählen.
Und so der wahrscheinlich stärkste Hersteller von Mobilfunk-Equipment ist Huawei,
die erstens in Leistungsfähigkeit der Konkurrenz voraus sind und zweitens auch bei den Preisen.
Jetzt gibt es seit mehreren Jahren Diskussionen darüber, ob man in Mobilfunknetzen
oder ob ob man diese Technologie dieses Herstellers in deutschen oder europäischen
Mobilfunknetzen überhaupt erlauben möchte oder nicht.
Argumentiert wird da regelmäßig über, sagen wir mal, Überwachungs- und oder
Sabotage-Möglichkeiten eines nicht vertrauenswürdigen chinesischen Unternehmens.
Ich denke, man kann sich aber ehrlicherweise auch darüber Gedanken machen,
ob man nicht derartig wichtige Infrastruktur auch wirklich selber bauen möchte.
Ob man nicht wirklich in Europa die Möglichkeit haben will.
Ein 5G-Netz zu bauen. Und das vielleicht lieber selber macht,
als sich hier in starke Abhängigkeiten eines chinesischen Herstellers zu begeben.
Die Argumentation wäre hier, also ich bleibe dabei,
dass ich weniger davon ausgehe, dass irgendwann in China eine Situation entsteht,
in der deutsche Mobilfunknetze abgeschaltet werden oder in der wirklich die Tatsache,
dass sie diese Infrastruktur gebaut haben oder dass sie Komponenten für diese
Infrastruktur geliefert haben, ausnutzen werden zur Überwachung.
Das halte ich nach wie vor für nicht so extrem wahrscheinlich.
Trotzdem hat sich natürlich an dieser Wahrscheinlichkeit etwas geändert,
spätestens seitdem wir gesehen wie Russland mit den Gaslieferungen umgegangen
ist, bei einer zu starken Abhängigkeit.
Ich bleibe aber dabei, dass es einfach von der Beschaffenheit von Mobilfunknetzen
nicht ohne weiteres möglich sein wird, dass.
Huawei Mitarbeiter deutsche Mobilfunknetze überwachen, ohne dass deutsche Mobilfunknetze
das bemerken oder das verhindern könnten.
Habe ich auch vor längerer Zeit mal ein bisschen was zugeschrieben,
mit einer Stellungnahme zum letzten IT-Sicherheitsgesetz.
Da ist es längere Zeit aufgeklärt, warum.
Und das liegt primär auch daran, dass die deutschen Mobilfunknetze Kunden sind
von deutschen Unternehmen,
also der Huawei Deutschland GmbH, die dann irgendwie zufälligerweise in Bonn
oder Düsseldorf einen Sitz hat und von dort aus diese Komponenten liefert und
deren Mitarbeiter intime Einblicke in diese Infrastrukturen haben.
Was ich als das viel größere Problem sehe, als dass jetzt eine Backdoor in einer der Komponenten wäre.
Also, Summary, ich glaube, es ist kritischer, dass die überhaupt an diesen Infrastrukturen,
also die Mitarbeiter diese Einblicke haben und damit natürlich auch sehr viel
mehr wissen, das, was nur ihre einzelnen Komponenten betrifft,
als dass jetzt aus China diese Komponenten geliefert werden.
Los ging das eigentlich mit Trump vor ein paar Jahren, der dann gesagt hat,
ok, Huawei aus den Mobilfunknetzen raus.
Und argumentiert wurde das mit Spionageschutz und durchgedrückt wurde das sogar gegenüber Deutschen,
dass die USA gesagt haben, pass auf, wenn ihr eure Mobilfunknetze weiter mit
Huawei baut, dann werden wir mit euch keine Informationen mehr teilen.
Was natürlich doppelt übel ist, aber okay, also es gibt ja diese Diskussion
und jetzt widmet sich die Bundesregierung wieder ein bisschen mehr in Richtung eines harten Kurses.
Innenministerium und Auswärtiges Amt möchten also Huawei jetzt vollständig rauswerfen
Und das Verkehrs- und Digitalministerium eines,
nicht zwei, es ist eins, BMDV, sagt natürlich,
naja, okay, das sind Austauschkosten in Milliardenhöhe,
wir müssen mit Entschädigungsklagen rechnen von den Betreibern,
die diese Komponenten verbaut haben und deswegen wird ein großflächiger Austausch
auch die Netzausbaupläne gefährden,
ja, wenn jetzt aus, wenn die Deutsche Telekom Nebenbau mal ein Netz mit ordentlicher
Abdeckung, jetzt auch noch große Teile der bestehenden Infrastruktur rückbauen
müsste oder durch andere Komponenzen ersetzen müsste, wird schwierig.
Ich bin gespannt. Also Telefonica sagt, sollte es zu einem Ausschluss einzelner
Komponenten kommen, muss entsprechend ausreichend langer Zeitraum für diesen
Austausch gegeben werden.
Und wir würden selbstverständlich für einen rückwirkenden, notwendigen Umbau
des Netzes Schadensersatzsprecher gegen die Bundesrepublik Deutschland prüfen, ja, soweit Telefonica.
Und natürlich ist das auch erstmal grob verständlich.
Ja ich meine der Krieg hatte jetzt in der Tat eine neue,
wie soll ich sagen, das Szenario gab es ja sicherlich auch schon vorher,
es konnte sich bisher so noch recht keiner vorstellen und es hat ja nicht nur
die Dimension von Entzug, was ja zum Beispiel mit dem Gas gemeint,
Sondern ist natürlich auch mittlerweile jetzt eine Frage des Revenue-Streams.
Also dürfen die sozusagen an unserer Infrastruktur noch mitverdienen.
Ziehen wir jetzt China raus oder wollen wir zumindest die Möglichkeit haben
sie rauszuhalten aus kritischen Infrastrukturen,
wo sie uns unter Umständen Gegendruck liefern können, wenn wir aus welchen Gründen
auch immer, Stichwort Einmarsch in Taiwan uns genötigt sehen in irgendeiner Form Druck zu machen.
Also wenn man jetzt mal das Ukraine-Krieg-Szenario auf einen möglichen Konflikt
der Westmächte mit China im Rahmen der Taiwan-Frage mal so interpolieren und
man würde sich jetzt entscheiden,
auch genauso sich aus einem chinesischen Markt herauszuziehen,
was sicherlich nochmal viel, viel mehr Opfer nach sich ziehen würde,
also wirtschaftliche Opfer nach sich ziehen würde im Westen,
als das jetzt schon in Russland der Fall ist.
Aber dann will man sozusagen den Rücken frei haben. Das fließt jetzt hier sicherlich
in die Diskussion mit ein, auch wenn das glaube ich am Anfang dann doch eher
wirklich aus dieser Spionagerhetorik heraus geboren wurde.
Ja und ich würde sagen es war immer diese Wirtschaftsüberlegung.
Also meine These ist, dass es die immer war und ich finde die auch nachträglich,
also habt ihr auch immer gewissermaßen berechtigt gefunden.
Also sagt ihr im Motto Geld was die nicht verdienen, verdienen wir?
Ja.
Oder wie? Ja, aber ist das nicht ein bisschen sehr einfach?
Weiß ich nicht, also die verdienen schon eine ganze Menge Geld damit.
Ja gut ja klar, aber ich meine freier Wettbewerb lalala,
ich meine es ist ja auch nicht so als ob ich jetzt nur China bei uns Technologie
verkaufen würde, sondern der Westen verkauft ja auch sehr viel Technologie in
China und die entsprechende Retourkutsche.
Was denn, Dieselmotoren oder was, das hat sich jetzt langsam erledigt.
Ja, in der Automobilbranche sieht es anders aus, aber was verkaufen wir noch nach China?
Ja, Elektronik vor allem, also die Chiptechnologie, die moderne,
die kommt halt aus Taiwan und nicht aus China.
Achso, ah ok, und du zählst Taiwan zum Westen.
Ja klar, Taiwan zähle ich zum Teil, also halte ich für einen Teil des westlichen Systems.
Ich meine die USA garantieren da militärisch für Stabilität.
Und machen sich ja wenige klar darüber, wo eigentlich die Elektronik herkommt
und wie wenig Unternehmen letzten Endes die Vorherrschaft im Elektroniksektor sicherstellen.
Und es ist halt im Wesentlichen ein paar Unternehmen in Taiwan und ein Unternehmen
in den Niederlanden, die sozusagen da den Fortschritt festhalten.
Also ich bin mal gespannt.
Du hast auf jeden Fall mit einem Punkt recht, ja sollte eine solche Entscheidung wirklich fallen,
dann wäre das zunächst einmal eine Maßnahme,
die man Wirtschaftskonflikt nennt und das würde mit einer Vergeltung,
üblicherweise in ähnlicher Höhe und Schadenspotenzial begegnet werden.
Absolut. Damit muss man auf jeden Fall rechnen. Das könnte schmerzhaft werden für beide Seiten.
Könnte schmerzhaft werden, ja.
Okay, kommen wir zum letzten Thema. Wir haben in der letzten oder vorletzten Sendung gesagt,
dass das Landgericht Karlsruhe entschieden hatte, dass der Journalist des Freien
Senders Radio Dreieck, Land.
Der in einem Artikel einen Link auf Linksuntenpunkt in die Media gesetzt hatte,
nicht dafür vor Gericht muss.
Jetzt hat das Oberlandesgericht Stuttgart diesen Beschluss des Landgerichts
in zweiter Instanz aufgehoben und es soll doch eine Hauptverhandlung stattfinden.
Es war ja quasi ein Bericht darüber,
dass links unten in den Medien als kriminelle Vereinigung verboten wurde und
damit ist die Unterstützung strafbar und seit diesem Verbot von vor fünf Jahren
ist es nur noch eine Archivseite,
es erscheinen dort keine neuen Artikel.
Und das OLG Stuttgart argumentiert jetzt,
es sei überwiegend wahrscheinlich,
dass die Vereinigung weiterhin existiere, weil
das Archiv ja noch online ist und deswegen
ist quasi dorthin zu linken eine Verlängerung der Internetseite und Deswegen
ist es mit überwiegender Wahrscheinlichkeit Unterstützung dieser Organisation
und nicht von der Pressefreiheit gedeckt.
Den fällt auch bald nichts Gutes mehr ein, ne? Also das klingt ja noch nicht mal mehr kreativ.
Also es ist wirklich absurd, es ist absurd, dass das jetzt irgendwie ein...
Offenbar ist der dort erschienene Inhalt ja auch nicht illegal,
weil sonst hätten die, sonst wäre es denen ja gelungen, den offline zu nehmen, ja.
Also es war ja schon ohnehin so, dass diese Seite nicht verfolgt wurde wegen ihrer Inhalte,
sondern dass den Betreibenden der Seite unterstellt wurde, eine kriminelle Vereinigung
zu sein. Also es ist wirklich, wirklich verrückt.
Auch wenn man nicht wusste, um welche Personen es sich dabei handelt,
weil es diese Organisation als solche ja gar nicht gibt.
Die Organisation gab es ja nicht. Soweit ich mich erinnere, und da werden wir
uns jetzt, da wurde ich schon mal zu korrigiert, dass alle Verfahren gegen Linksunten
in den Medien ja am Ende auch ergebnislos eingestellt wurden.
Ja, weil sie gesagt haben, naja, okay, also die Existenz dieser Vereinigung
kann man irgendwie nicht nachweisen.
Und ob die Vereinigung dann auch noch kriminell wäre, ist auch noch unklar.
Also letztendlich haben sie gesagt, hier dieser, ähm, also sie haben gesagt,
das ist eine kriminelle Vereinigung, die das macht.
Und die Mitgliedschaft darin ist jetzt irgendwie halt dann strafbar.
Und dann haben sie am Ende noch nicht mal feststellen können,
dass die Vereinigung kriminell ist. Also irgendwo beißen sie sich da alle in
den, äh, in den Schwanz in ihrer Argumentation.
Ich habe nach wie vor den Eindruck, dass es da die ganze Zeit nur darum geht, dass die...
A. eingeschüchtert werden sollen.
B. dass es möglichst darum geht, dieses Thema halt lange in den Medien zu halten
und lange in der Nichtentscheidung zu halten, um hier allen möglichen Leuten
einfach nur richtig Ärger zu machen. Und der...
Wo ist er? Der Name des Anwalts von der GFF.
David Westermann, der das Verfahren bei der GFF koordiniert,
sagt, die Verlinkung der Archivseite ist keine Propaganda, sondern gehört zu
den Aufgaben der digitalen Presse.
Wenn Medien mit Strafverfahren rechnen müssen, nur weil sie kritisch über staatliche
Vereinsverbote berichten, dann bleibt von der Pressefreiheit nicht mehr viel übrig.
Also die Argumentation würde mich dann am Ende wirklich mal interessieren,
also was dann dieser Link tatsächlich klassifiziert wird.
Also wir meinen, dass es vielleicht eine Organisation gibt, die unter Umständen
eine terroristische Vereinigung sein könnte, wenn sie es denn gäbe,
was wir nicht nachweisen können, weil wir niemanden kennen, der in ihr drin ist.
Und obwohl die Inhalte, die da durch eine Webseite repräsentiert werden,
so überhaupt nicht strafbar sind, weil dann wären sie ja schon weg,
darf man nicht drauf verlinken, weil es könnte ja unter Umständen beschwören,
dass es dann doch irgendwann wahr wird, dass es sich dann doch um eine terroristische
Vereinigung handeln könnte.
Also so ein Beschwörungs-Link sozusagen.
Wenn du links unten googlest, ist dieses Archiv der erste Link.
Und da steht dann links unten in die media.org verboten, Archiv bleibt erhalten.
In die Media links unten wurde am 25. August 2017 vom Bundesinnenminister verboten.
Die Seite bleibt als Archiv erhalten. Die einzigen Archive der Bewegungen haben
die Bewegungen selbst hervorgebracht.
Und niemand wird unsere Geschichte erzählen, wenn wir es nicht selbst tun.
Bewegungen müssen Spuren ihrer Leidenschaft für zukünftige Generationen hinterlassen,
denn vergessene Kämpfe sind verlorene Kämpfe.
Da steht das jetzt irgendwie drin, du kannst es auch runterladen,
irgendwie HTML 1 Gigabyte mit Medien 85 Gigabyte als JSON 300 MB,
also das wird halt archiviert.
Und dann wird zu Spenden an eine Organisation mit dem Namen Tajanka aufgerufen,
aber ich sehe ehrlich gesagt, es ist schon wirklich schwierig.
Also entweder gibt es jetzt hier illegale Inhalte in diesem Archiv,
dann würde ich erwarten, dass die Staatsanwaltschaft gegen die Zugänglichmachung
dieses Archives vorgeht, das tut sie aber offenbar seit nunmehr sechs Jahren nicht.
Und damit wird mir irgendwie schwer nachvollziehbar, warum sie gegen jemanden
vorgehen, der im Rahmen einer Presseberichterstattung darauf verlinkt,
dass es dieses Archiv gibt.
Also, kommt mir ein bisschen so vor. Also auch, dass sich Landesgerichte,
Oberlandesgerichte, Staatsanwaltschaften mit so etwas befassen,
erscheint mir irgendwie nicht im Rahmen der sinnvollen Verwendung ihrer Ressourcen zu liegen.
Von unseren Gebühren.
Mit meinen Steuergeldern, mit meinen Geldset-Gebühren machen die das.
Okay, kommen wir zu den Terminen. Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, Tim. Okay.
Ja, da sind sie wieder, die Termine
und es geht los hier mit einem Kindernachmittag im X-Heim in Berlin,
die Nachricht, hallo Tim und Linus, leider waren wir ja beim letzten Kindernachmittag
zu spät dran mit der Ankündigung in LNP, wenn ihr jetzt den nächsten Kindernachmittag am 2.
Juli 2023 in die Termine aufnehmen könntet, wäre das super. Ich hoffe das ist
jetzt gleichzeitig, machen wir doch glatt.
2.7.13 Uhr, Kindernachmittag im X-Heim, das X-Heim ist in Berlin Friedrichsheim.
So sieht's aus.
Und dann? Dann gibt es noch einen Termin in Dresden, dort finden wieder im September
die Datenspuren statt, im Zentralwerk.
Und was jetzt der entscheidende Hinweis ist, der CFP, also der Call for Participation, ist bis zum 31.07.
Geöffnet und da könnt ihr also eure Einreichung zu dieser Veranstaltung machen.
Entsprechenden Link findet ihr in den Shownotes und wir sehen uns in Dresden.
Hast du gesagt wann?
Ja, 16.09. bis 17.09. Hab ich vielleicht nicht gesagt, ehrlich gesagt.
Oder ich hab's nicht gehört.
Und bis 31.07. Einreichung.
Genau. Ja, das war's dann eigentlich auch schon mit unserem Termin und das war's
dann auch mit unserer Sendung.
Mit dieser Episode, nicht mit unserer Sendung.
Jaja, mit dieser Episode.
Ja, die Leute erschrecken sich so. Ja wir haben leider die ganze Zeit auf Huawei
aufgezeichnet, tut uns leid wir müssen das jetzt zurück bauen.
Ja genau das kann teuer werden. Ja ne mit dieser Episode mit dieser Ausgabe
dieser Inkarnation dieser einzelnen Instanz dieser Medienunternehmung das ist
jetzt vorbei aber nächste Woche oder so müssen wir uns dann wieder empfangen in euren Hörgeräten.
Neuartigen Empfangsgeräten. So vorbei. Wir sagen tschüss. Tschau.
Tschau tschau.